mi libro se ha convertido en una especie
de centro estratégico para la vocación
de decenas de miles de civiles que están
huyendo de las regiones del este del
país ante una inminente ofensiva de las
tropas rusas las zonas de done ex lugar
y también clamatos después de que la
estación de tren haya sido bombardeada
hace unos días convierten a la estación
de tren de dmitro en la única salida
para los miles de civiles que no quieren
que se repita la experiencia como ya ha
ocurrido en manipule donde decenas de
miles de personas siguen atrapadas o lo
que hemos visto desgraciadamente en la
región de kiev en la ciudad de lucha y
en otras ciudades que han sido
recientemente liberadas al menos 10.000
personas han llegado en los últimos días
ante esa inminente ofensiva que aunque
todavía no ha empezado los civiles no
quieren que puedan quedarse en medio del
fuego cruzado y allí puedan repetirse
estas atrocidades